Este edificio tenía que recibir
2500 caballos pura sangre realmente muy nerviosos
que venían de vuelos de larga distancia,
con mucho jet lag, y que no estaban en su mejor momento.
Los ingenieros enfrentaron este problema:
¿qué cantidad de desechos atender?
No enseñan esto en la facultad de ingeniería (Risas)
y no es el tipo de cosas en las que uno quisiera equivocarse,
podría haber pasado meses hablando con veterinarios, investigando,
ajustando la hoja de cálculo.
En vez de eso, pidió ayuda
y encontró a alguien que había diseñado el Jockey Club de Nueva York.
El problema se resolvió en menos de un día.
Arup cree que la cultura de la ayuda
es central para su éxito.
Lo de ayuda suena algo endeble,
pero es absolutamente medular para los equipos de éxito,
y supera a diario a la inteligencia individual.
Ayudar implica que no tengo que saberlo todo,
solo tengo que trabajar con personas que saben dar y recibir ayuda.
En SAP calculan que pueden responder cualquier pregunta en 17 minutos.
Pero no es la única empresa de alta tecnología con la que he trabajado
que imagina por un momento que se trata de un problema de tecnología,
porque lo que mueve a la ayuda es que la gente se conozca.
Suena muy obvio, y pensamos que se dará naturalmente,
pero no es así.
Cuando gestionaba mi primera empresa de software,
me di cuenta de que estábamos estancados.
Había mucha fricción, pero no mucho más,
y me fui dando cuenta de que las personas brillantes que contraté
no se conocían entre ellos.
Estaban tan concentrados en su trabajo individual,
que ni sabían a quién tenían al lado,
y fue entonces que insistí en que dejáramos de trabajar
e invirtiéramos tiempo en conocernos unos a otros
y que tomaramos impulso de verdad.
Eso fue hace 20 años, y ahora visito empresas
que han prohibido las tazas de café en los escritorios
porque quieren que la gente se reúna en torno a la máquina de café para conversar.
Los suecos tienen un término especial para esto.
Lo llaman "fika", que significa más que una pausa para el café.
Significa "restauración colectiva".
En Idexx, una empresa de Maine,
han creado huertos en el campus para que las personas
de diferentes áreas del negocio
puedan trabajar juntos y conocer así todo el negocio.
¿Se han vuelto locos?
Todo lo contrario; han advertido que cuando la cosa se complica,
y siempre se complicará,
si uno hace un trabajo disruptivo que realmente importa,
las personas necesitan soporte social,
y tienen que saber a quién pedir ayuda.
Las empresas no tienen ideas; solo las personas las tienen.
Y lo que motiva a las personas
son los lazos, la lealtad, y la confianza que desarrollan unos con otros.
Importa el mortero,
no solo los ladrillos.
Cuando juntamos todo esto,
tenemos algo llamado capital social.
El capital social es la dependencia
y la interdependencia que genera confianza.
El término viene de los sociólogos que estudiaban las comunidades
que eran resistentes en momentos de estrés.
El capital social es lo que da impulso a las empresas,
el capital social es lo que hace robustas a las empresas.
¿Qué significa esto en la práctica?
Significa que el tiempo lo es todo,
porque el capital social se compone con el tiempo.
A los equipos que trabajan juntos más tiempo, les va mejor porque lleva tiempo
desarrollar la confianza necesaria para llegar a la franqueza y la apertura.
El tiempo construye valor.
Cuando Alex Pentland le sugirió a una empresa
que sincronice las pausas para el café
para que las personas puedan conversar
las ganancias subieron USD 15 millones,
y la satisfacción de los empleados subió un 10 %.
No es un mal retorno sobre el capital social,
y se compone conforme lo gastas.
Pero no se trata de camaradería, ni de incentivar vagos,
porque las personas que trabajan así suelen ser un poco ásperas,
impacientes, absolutamente determinadas a pensar por sí mismas
porque esa es su contribución.
El conflicto es frecuente porque la franqueza está a salvo.
Y así las buenas ideas se vuelven grandes ideas,
porque ninguna idea nace ya formada del todo.
Emerge un poco como nace un niño,
en el caos y la confusión, pero pleno de posibilidades.
Y solo gracias a la contribución generosa, la fe y el desafío
es que logran su potencial.
Eso es lo que apoya el capital social.
Pero no solemos hablar de esto,
sobre el talento, sobre creatividad, de esta manera.
Solemos hablar de estrellas.
Por eso empecé a preguntarme: si empezamos a trabajar así,
¿implica el fin de las estrellas?
Y fui a las audiciones
en la Real Academia de Arte Dramático de Londres.
Y allí vi algo que me sorprendió, porque los profesores
no buscaban pirotecnia individual.
Buscaban lo que ocurría entre los estudiantes,
porque en eso yace el drama.
Y hablando con productores de álbumes exitosos,
me dijeron: "Claro, tenemos muchas superestrellas de la música.
pero no perduran demasiado.
Solo los colaboradores destacados disfrutan de largas carreras,
porque sacando lo mejor de los otros es como encuentran lo mejor en ellos".
Y cuando fui a visitar empresas célebres
por su ingenio y creatividad,
no encontré superestrellas,
porque todos allí importaban.
Y al reflexionar sobre mi propia carrera,
y las personas extraordinarias con las que tuve el privilegio de trabajar,
me di cuenta de cuánto más podríamos darnos mutuamente
si dejáramos de tratar de ser supergallinas.
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Una vez que uno aprecia de verdad cómo es el trabajo social,
muchas cosas tienen que cambiar.
La gestión por concurso de talentos ha enfrentado de manera rutinaria
a los empleados unos contra otros.
La rivalidad tiene que ser reemplazada por el capital social.
Durante décadas, hemos intentado motivar a las personas con dinero,
a pesar de contar con gran cantidad de investigación que muestra
que el dinero erosiona la conexión social.
Ahora, tenemos que dejar que las personas motiven a los demás.
Durante años, pensamos que los líderes eran héroes solitarios y se esperaba
que por sí mismos, resolvieran problemas complejos.
Tenemos que redefinir el liderazgo
como una actividad en la que se crean las condiciones
para que cada uno pueda brindar el pensamiento más valiente, juntos.
Sabemos que eso funciona.
Cuando el Protocolo de Montreal llamó a la eliminación gradual de los CFC,
los clorofluorocarbonos implicados en el agujero en la capa de ozono,
los riesgos eran inmensos.
Los CFC estaban por doquier,
y nadie sabía si se podía encontrar un sustituto.
Pero un equipo que aceptó el reto adoptó 3 principios clave.
El primero fue el jefe de ingeniería, Frank Maslen, que dijo:
no habrá estrellas en este equipo.
Necesitamos a todos.
Todo el mundo tiene una perspectiva válida.
Segundo, trabajamos con una norma única:
lo mejor imaginable.
Y tercero, le dijo a su jefe, Geoff Tudhope,
que tenía que alejarse,
porque sabía lo perjudicial que puede ser el poder.
Esto no significó que Tudhope no hiciera nada.
Le dio cobertura al equipo,
y escuchaba para garantizar que honraban sus principios.
Funcionó: Por delante de otras empresas que abordaron este difícil problema,
este grupo lo hizo primero.
Hasta la fecha, el Protocolo de Montreal
es el acuerdo ambiental de mayor éxito internacional
implementado en la historia.
Había mucho en juego entonces,
y hay mucho en juego ahora,
y no resolveremos nuestros problemas si esperamos
que sea resuelto por unos pocos superhombres o supermujeres.
Necesitamos a todos,
porque solo cuando aceptemos que todos tenemos un valor
será cuando liberaremos la energía, la imaginación y el impulso necesarios
para crear lo mejor inconmensurable.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)